[Music]
one of southern nevada's most
controversial politicians will run for
governor city of las vegas councilwoman
michelle fiore made that announcement
just this morning the i-team's vanessa
murphy was there and explains fiore's
proposed plan and also the candidate's
history vanessa denise part of michelle
fiore's message is don't expect her to
compromise and she's a fighter she
didn't take reporter questions today but
her campaign consultant did and when
asked about her controversial past he's
saying she's targeted because she's so
outspoken
and i am running for governor
michelle fiori announcing a run for
governor as a republican candidate and
her campaign releasing this video fan
vaccine mandates ban critical race
theory
and stop voter fraud
the joe biden administration is coming
after me fiore's campaign consultant
rory mcshane confirms the fbi served the
city of las vegas councilwoman with a
subpoena in january and says she's fully
cooperating although it's unclear what
the investigation is about also this
year councilwoman victoria seaman once a
close ally says fiore physically
assaulted her in city hall michelle
viewer and victoria simmons are both
enthusiastic elected officials who serve
who
proudly and serve the people they do
passionate people getting arguments with
other passionate people that's just what
happens i think i think and hopefully
that will be put to bed in the near
future fiore faced controversy in 2020
there was an effort to recall her which
failed she used city resources to
promote the re-election of donald trump
and the naacp asked for her removal and
referred to a quote lack of remorse for
racist comments and quote councilman
cedric creer in a letter wrote that
multiple witnesses heard fiore saying i
am a white woman and i should not lose
my job because of their black expletive
fiore did not admit making the comments
but apologized and stepped down as mayor
pro tem i never ever
want to portray or have anyone believe
that there is a racist bone in my body
can you clarify what was said on the
record right now
i the councilwoman did not make any
racist comments in 2015 as a state
assembly woman she said this i can tell
you the great respect i have for my pr
mr munn for being the first colored man
to graduate his college
we're in 2015 and we have a
black president in case anyone didn't
notice
so
the color and the race issue
i think it's time that we put that to
rest
and we go forth controversy after
controversy for a republican candidate
vying for the top job in state
government baggage is a by-product when
you fight as loudly and proudly as
someone like michelle fiori working with
pelosi
fiori's campaign consultant says she
will likely be available for interviews
this week
and fiore jones joins i should say five
other republicans who have already
announced they'll be running for
governor here's a look at the list clark
county sheriff joe lombardo along with
north las vegas mayor john lee former
senator dean heller along with venture
capitalist guy nora and former
professional boxer joey gilbert now by
the way the winner of the republican
primary will go on to face governor
sisselek in november